Washington Times opinion editor Fox News
contributor Charlie you and I have
talked about the
um you know the the renaming of
pedophilia into something that's more
acceptable you know minor attracted
persons the hashtag on that was on
Twitter for the longest I might still be
for all I know
um but this is mainstreaming something
which is sick and frankly felonious
yeah at some point you have to stop and
wonder if it's not all intentional
because it sure does seem like it's all
intentional and I think that the degree
to which you have a lot of people on the
left and at these social media companies
talking about white supremacy and trying
to promote this idea that there are all
these white supremacists that are all
over the internet and all over uh taking
over our country meanwhile they're
ignoring real criminal acts like in this
case with Instagram and this study where
you have child pedophilia you have child
pornography being distributed on their
platform and as you point out this you
know imagine how much uh maybe Mark
Zuckerberg might have been able to clean
up his own website uh from peddling this
crap If instead of spending a half
billion dollars to hijack the 2020
election he had spent trying to clean it
up but the other thing I think is
interesting here is you know the reason
Democrats don't care about this and you
went through all of that that in in your
monologue brilliantly the reason they
don't care about it is because they
can't weaponize it to their advantage
they want to talk about this stuff they
want to talk about the evils out there
only if they can create a boogeyman that
not only silences as you point out
silences their opponents but also
frightens their followers into thinking
that the other side is out to get them I
think Charlie you're making such a great
point and it reminds me this is why they
really get their their hair up on their
backs when you say you're trying to
groom these kids what else do you call
this like what else is this if you're
telling six-year-olds no you're not a
boy you're a girl good let's change your
name get the skirt on everyone you have
to call this boy by the new it's
ridiculous and it's and it's an attempt
to get kids used to being sexual beings
before most of them can do basic math
and reading that's what this is all
about enforce I'm gonna say it till I'm
blowing the face compliance
yeah and forcing the children to
participate in their fantasy charade and
what you know one of the things that
this study found on Instagram was that
that uh before child abuse images would
pop up Instagram would provide a warning
saying that the this search result could
result with uh pictures of child abuse
but then gave the user the option to
ignore it and go ahead and look at the
at the child abuse photographs anyway so
my goodness what are these people doing
they're not even pretending to care
about this stuff they use children as
political pawns that's in the end that's
all they are to them now maida which of
course owns Instagram Facebook they're
claiming that they're taking action to
try to stop this problem they're forming
of course they all stand by the task
force to investigate how the app
facilitates the spread and sale of child
sexual abuse material where's the
Attorney General Here Charlie are they
still worrying about you know they're
getting next grand jury against Trump
where's it where is our attorney general
who says that white supremacy is the
biggest problem facing the country
got kids being exactly no that's a great
yep no it's it's and it's just it's
black and white it's child abuse and
it's bullying and it's disgusting but if
they can't use it to to uh you know uh
benefit them them politically they do
not care yeah Charlie if they can't use
it to ballot Harvest it's not a problem
for the day right we're gonna put it off
for the next next year Charlie uh thank
you for this we appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else